but you have to like deal with some of
the traumatic stuff what's the traumatic
stuff
um I mean maybe just being a single mom
to two
because that's a lot what she says is
true I can be an and I could
block things out and I could just want
to laugh things off it's just how I cope
with things I never said it was healthy
I just said it's how I cope with things
it would be probably like emotionally
clearing and refreshing if you just like
had a good cry like
I hate this place I hate all these
things that are going like I'm I'm being
serious but then what does that do after
you'll see after you're finished you
have to try oh my gosh don't worry about
me
that's well that's not gonna happen I
can't can't get me down
stop
don't make me laugh people keep trying
you can't can't take me out
I'm here to stay